we get we get a little intense every
time we talk
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh i feel it's
like yeah it's like
it's like uh like how cosell
in my valley is no no look i had great
intense interviews with him
he'll look back like no no no no no i
have the best footage
like yes yes yes like bird bird
like i have people kind of like now if
you want to have
good footage at my funeral these are the
four people that you need to contact
like no no they have the best [ __ ] like
they have the best [ __ ]
like it's like joy diaz has
some good stuff jordy is like oh no no
brother
when you when you [ __ ] when you
die now i'm gonna put this [ __ ] out and
like yo it's gonna be
spectacular like what the [ __ ] you think
i'm gonna die before your whole life
are you saying we're in that level where
we captured some
unique ali yeah man it's it's
every interview is is is different with
different people that's the craziest
thing
it's like just like my stand-up i'm
different with
different play but it's it's genuinely
me it's just a different
people bring out like i'm very
comfortable with
bert burke talk about what if i laugh a
lot
with him because he's just when somebody
come into your room with no shirt on
and no shoes any toenail one toenail
pain and he's like
so when you raise about a single mother
like what
like
that's like jumping into this thing yeah
single mother right okay
all right so um cause your room is
amazing
i'm like no not right now but you know
it's like it's just a it's a weird thing
man
and then ari is a little weirder the art
is like
yo we should do shrooms together and
then do a podcast
and then you think about it like and
then you go to joys and get
wasted with joy and like yo and you're
waiting to do rogan
you want to do tom score you want you
know you just people that you
want to do you know you want to say i
want i have a goal
of doing these podcasts i want to do
you know times go on i want to do
brogan i want to do i want to go on i
want to be the first person to ever go
on
um bill burr's podcast i think he just
does this by itself
he does like yeah i just i want to go on
billboard's podcast
just just me and him the only person
they ever do
they go down in history and i put that
in the credit the only man's ever do
bill birth false cash
that'll be my uh i'll take all the rest
of my [ __ ] out comedy center and all
that dude
that's my goal with this podcast because
so many comedians have a podcast that i
want to talk to comedians
in a way they've never been talked to
before and like get more on the insights
of their process and like how they got
to where they are and things like that
because so many comics have a podcast
i'd like this to be one where people can
come to learn
i don't i don't do everybody's podcast
just know that i don't
i by no means do i do everybody's pocket
respect i have no desire i do joke
buttons
[Music]
but i i don't have a desire to do it
i'll do anything with nikki glacier
anything
with nikki glenn well thanks for letting
us be a part of that exclusive list
ollie sadiq oh yeah
it's only a it's a very exclusive list
worldwide 20 people i'll do they podcast
worldwide
there's not a lot of people
because i don't like a lot of people you
you i've been in radio interviews what
the [ __ ] they got like man you know how
[ __ ] about you in his interviews like it
so he didn't got like that like
like a lot of who the [ __ ] is you
talking to on the radio interview so i
don't like doing a lot of different
people's interviews
yeah and i'm like [ __ ] with you [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] stooge
he told me that he gonna beat my hands
and he's like yeah like i don't give a
[ __ ] about
coming up here no one you can ban me you
don't give a [ __ ]
man when you can't a dude like me that
that been in prison that know he's not
ever going back
like i'm a whole court in the street if
they ever try that [ __ ]
it's not a lot you can [ __ ] say or do
to me that i'm like yo man
either you're gonna have to try to prove
that [ __ ] i'ma prove exactly what i said
i'm doing but i
guarantee i'ma [ __ ] prove it because
i don't come from a place where you can
say some [ __ ] you can't do it
i was six years in prison my informative
years 1925.
if i sell them and do something if i
make that decision you know something
you know um
i'll [ __ ] kick your teeth down your
throat just know you're gonna have to go
to the dentist
[Music]
yeah and you're capable that's what's
scary just know you
[ __ ] going to the dentist it's like
i'm telling you
you didn't you didn't push me through
but i'm like yo man i go over here
eating sugar babies
and you used to start [ __ ] with me
and then there it is man all of a sudden
that
i leave the bad guy but nobody else i
try not my best not to get into nothing
because it's always my fault no matter
a dude could shoot me and then i'll beat
his ass then they go like
see see that's why the [ __ ] shot
you
cause you be like no no i got shot
yeah i want to end this before i get
kicked in the teeth nah man you're good
man that's what's up uh our um
i was our dialogue was just very
muhammad ali howard costello i'm gonna
i'm gonna go watch some of that i gotta
i don't even know the reference why
would you see the reference you're gonna
[ __ ] fall out you're like
yeah that is it's kind of like this
thing
because they were at each other all the
time they were the bet they always had
the best goddamn interviews
that's awesome that line was muhammad
ali
the critics say that you're not what you
used to be
and how and he told how go say he said
well howard
i talked to your wife last night and she
said you have the man that you used to
be
[ __ ] hysterical to me in the areas
it's like they just
back and forth yeah every time i'm gonna
go watch something i'm gonna come to
your show tonight too i'll see the
master at work
i always learn seeing you work man